where are you from
from sudan
have you come from cali have you come
from calais
how many of you one two three four five
17 people 12
17 14 13 of you are you okay you don't
have life jackets
you don't have jackets
we're just coming alongside you might be
able to see in the distance
the fourth boat of migrants that we have
seen
so far today and i have to say you know
it is an unsettling
image coming this close hello
you okay okay
are you okay
where are you from
we're very close you can see to um the
white cliffs of dover now
our boat um driver is just calling the
coast guard now so obviously we'll stay
with this boat make sure
it's safe as it comes into shore but it
really has been quite an extraordinary
morning out on the english channel of
course we know this is now
a very familiar scene that doesn't make
it any less
unsettling to see we have seen three
boats
already this is the fourth one the first
was in
the distance quite a way off towards
french waters and the second
um as we came back towards dave we got
really quite close there
as well and they were cheering uk as we
drove past that second book
well in a moment we're going to hear
from our europe correspondent michelle
clifford who's in calais and our
political correspondent kate mccann
who's in westminster first though let's
go to dover speak to ash nahura now get
ashna as we
we're hearing from ali there uh four
boats that she'd spotted today what
what's happening in dover what happens
when they get there
well just a few moments ago we spotted
those suspected migrants that my
colleague ali fortescue spoke to there
people from sudan kurdistan iran
um making their way to shore here at
dover they were all wearing life jackets
by this point that's because they've
been picked up by a border force vessel
and then transferred over to the jetty
here where they were met
by authorities and police coast guard as
well who are taking their details
checking their temperature of course we
are in the midst of a pandemic still so
all of those checks do need to go ahead
this only adds now to the total of more
than 700 migrants
having made their way ashore here to
dover in small boats over the last
six days and those calm conditions only
make it
um more more of a take people taking
advantage of those calm conditions
but it doesn't mean that those waters
are calm
and still they are particularly quite
treacherous out in the middle of the
channel there we saw ali there being
um sort of surrounded by waves and if
you're in that small dinghy being driven
by often a very inexperienced pilot and
that can be incredibly dangerous and as
we heard a lot of those boats are
overwhelmed with the amount of people
that are on them we saw a majority of
them in those boats and men we did
however see one
female in there that ali referenced
yesterday here in dover we saw the home
secretary pretty patel
uh seeing for herself the issues that
the border force here having to contend
with she went out to see and saw
first hand we also saw yesterday the
ministry of defense
uh deplored an raf aircraft to
oversee the crossings from the skies
it'll be interesting to see whether we
see any of that today
of course those talks which my
colleagues will talk about shortly are
going ahead in paris later
today but among all the things they're
going to be discussing there is one
thing that britain and france
can't change and that's the geography of
where i am and of where we are
in relation to france we are 20 miles
away from
calais and no walls no blockades in the
middle of the ocean millie of the
channel i should say
is going to stop that from being a bit
of a magnet for those people
ash now thank you for that let's speak
to our europe correspondent michelle
clifford who's in calais michelle on
your side
you know there's a huge focus from
british politicians about the french
doing
more uh to stop people getting on those
boats in the first place give us an idea
of what it actually is like and how that
journey starts
well uh the the way it works is that the
migrants get in touch with the smugglers
they uh
pay them a fee and then they're told to
come to the beaches in calais
hide in the dunes and we filmed
overnight a couple of days ago
and we saw six migrants hiding in the
dunes and they wait for a phone call
from the
smugglers to say whether a boat is uh
coming or not they might have to come
back
uh several nights in a row but they're
handing over
huge sums of money as much as as little
as a thousand pounds and as much as
three or four
thousand pounds so the smugglers are
making a lot of money but they have no
regard really for the safety
of the people that they're putting into
these boats and they're very often
putting double and more the number of
people that should be on these
inflatables
a couple of nights ago we were on
another beach and we saw a boat
not heading away from calais but coming
in there was no sound of an engine
because the boat
was drifting and we managed to talk to
the migrants on board that vessel they'd
actually got out
into the channel were heading for the uk
and then suddenly
they realized they'd run out of fuel the
engine stopped working and local
fishermen say this is a common
occurrence the smugglers only put enough
fuel in
uh to allow the migrants to get into
british waters not to get to
uk uh shores and of course that meant
they were drifting they were incredibly
lucky because of the direction of the
wind
and it blew them back to france and they
got back here safely but they were very
lucky
not to have been hit by a large vessel
there are ferries
and tankers and ships traveling through
this area
um all of the time there is no shortage
of migrants here who are desperate to
get
uh to the uk they're willing to hand
over the money to the
smugglers and perhaps many of them don't
realize just how dangerous it is
out in the channel because on a clear
day
from here you can actually see the uk
shoreline it seems tantalizingly close
i really don't think that many of the
migrants realize quite what the risk
they are
taking yeah michelle thank you for that
let's go to westminster now speak to our
political correspondent kate mccann kate
the immigration minister chris philp
meeting his french counterpart today
this
is a has been an ongoing issue for
several years and there's been a lot of
money
try as you spent by both the british and
the french to try and solve this problem
so past just throwing money at it what
happens today potentially
well you're right about the fact that
this has been an ongoing issue now for
a number of years and you heard from
ashna and michelle some of the reasons
why it is still a really difficult
problem to solve
not least because there are people
willing to spend vast amounts of money
there are smugglers willing to help them
and as ashana said you can't change the
geography of where the two coastlines
are
so today this meeting chris phelp is
going out there on behalf of the uk
government it's designed really to sort
of lay the groundwork for priti patel
the home secretary to go out
later on when there is hopes of a deal
between the uk and france to try and do
more
to stop people from starting to make
that journey in the first place today
expect those talks to cover things like
the french doing more to police the
beaches where people leave from as
michelle was saying
it's quite well known there are around
five or six different areas where
migrants tend to leave
specific beaches the uk government wants
to see the french do more to patrol
those areas and stop people from making
the journey in the first place
and from the uk side there is a really
strong desire from boris johnson at the
top of government
to do more to send people back to france
if it can be proven that actually they
should have claimed asylum
in france in the first place now there
are a whole myriad of really complicated
rules governing this situation
including about the areas of safe
countries where you are supposed to or
you can make an application
and whether or not you can travel to
another safe country if you want to do
that
there are also rules around sending
people back and it's a really
complicated system that the government
will have to navigate if it wants to
make changes
all of course in the context of brexit
which makes everything much
more complex edward argher the health
minister was asked earlier on today
about the prime minister's intention
to change the laws what we are seeing
are people not only taking a legal route
in but an incredibly dangerous route for
them
and their families so it is in
everyone's interest
we tackle this what i think the prime
minister was referring to there is at
the moment
the approach to this and the returns of
people who come illegally to this
country
is governed by the dublin framework that
framework
does achieve the ability to return
illegal migrants back to france but it
can also it also has very short time
scales within which that could be done
it's very inflexible
i think what he's looking at quite
rightly
is greater flexibility in our ability to
negotiate something
which allows us greater flexibility in
returning people
who have come here illegal who've been
through due process and need to be
returned back to france
now there are all kinds of issues with
returning people
back to france there are the practical
issues of doing that the uk has actually
managed to return
fewer than 10 people using that
regulation so far because it's so
complicated and difficult to do
there are also issues like migrants
deliberately trying to hide their
fingerprints for example so it can't be
proven
where they came from and of course the
moral arguments too about asylum seekers
and whether the uk should be accepting
more people all of this will make it
very difficult
for the uk and france to strike a deal
but today is the first stage in that
process
and both sides hope they can do
something to deter people from making
that treacherous journey